so guys I just want to give her a little
message to UM Abdullah I know she's
gonna be watching this you know you took
everyone for a ride
may Allah forgive us inshallah she
repent sincerely if not may all that
deal with her yeah
very simple we don't care about nobody's
crocodile kiss
we've crossed that line yeah you put on
the new club after Laguna Cavite was
living a double life doing all kinds of
stuff yeah now you have no choice but to
keep that makeup on so nobody sees your
face nobody sees your face you're gonna
have to keep that makeup on now yes cuz
you can tell us everything are you gonna
cover your identity people are gonna see
you on the streets you know and they're
probably going to say oh look that's her
so how are you gonna cover your identity
you can after we're in the club now
you've stuck with that niqab you have no
choice but to wear it because that's
your safety now that what Allah
legislated you wear it properly now
you're gonna wear out of desperation and
this is how allah subhanho wa taala
immediates stove's who makes a mockery
of their religion and this Allah sponsor
that does that so your true face has
been shown literally literally as well
yeah so turn to your Lord he's forgiven
we human beings might may not be a lot
of people that you play around may not
forgive you and on the day of judgment
see a lot of people one injustice but
your Lord is inshallah most forgiving
inshallah so for you is well and sarra
yeah I'm sorry it was all in view all in
it and Hasan at you message me today I'm
not gonna get into detail don't worry
wait unless your video yeah
how about before you do any kind of
video you stop taking you're still in
doing inquiries you're still taking
customers what that is wrong with you
what is wrong with you okay here it is
my theory of what happened to these guys
yeah I thought if it's true or I don't
is a assumption these guys fell off the
team and the forces are formed in a
second
we do raka that's how we make our money
if you leave the religion okay but it's
connected to the rupiah so if we go and
say we've left or even if you don't tell
them we're gonna lose money
that's our living this how we make a
living and live our lavish double life
or if it may be
so therefore today self you know what we
have no choice but to just act it out
just carry on and do something we don't
believe him because it's this is what we
make money from that is a reason why
bothers and sisters one of the reasons
me personally and hijab and law brothers
Musa etc we try to disconnect the money
from the Dawa we try to disconnect as
much as we can believe me as much as we
can because we know what kind of fitna
can bring hamdulillah all of us have
side drops exception beside you in Dawa
that help us have that disconnection
this is what I believe happened